Nunca está de más practicar mucho, así que en
este video vamos a hacer varios ejemplos de
lo que llamamos divisiones largas. Empecemos.
Primero tenemos 4 que dividen y 2,292. No sé
exactamente por qué las llaman divisiones largas;
las hemos trabajado un poco en videos anteriores,
aunque no las llamé así, pero creo que las llaman
así porque toma más tiempo resolverlas o tal vez
porque se utiliza más espacio en el papel,
ya que a medida que avanzamos en la división
nos vamos quedando con esta larga cola que se
desarrolla al resolverla. Bueno al menos estas
son las razones que se me ocurren del por qué la
llaman división larga. En un video anterior vimos
que para abordar cualquier problema de divisiones
hay que conocer las tablas de multiplicar hasta,
tal vez 10 por 10 o 12 por 12; como repaso,
recuerda que esta división es lo mismo que
2,292 ÷ 4 y también es exactamente lo mismo que -y
probablemente no hayas visto antes esta notación-,
esto es lo mismo que 2,292 / 4. Esta, esta y esta
son proposiciones equivalentes de cierta forma,
y puedes decir: "Oye, Sal, eso parece una
fracción", si es que ya has visto fracciones,
y eso es exactamente lo que es, es una fracción.
De cualquier manera nos enfocaremos en esta forma
y en videos futuros pensaremos en otras formas
de representar una división, así que vamos a
resolverla. ¿Cuántas veces cabe 4 en 2? Cuatro
no cabe en dos, así que nos moveremos al 22.
¿Cuántas veces cabe 4 en 22? Veamos: 4 x 5 = 20,
4 x 6 = 24; con 6 nos pasamos, entonces 4 cabe 5
veces en 22. 5 x 4 es 20, así que vamos a tener
un sobrante, y después restamos: 22 - 20 esto
es 2 y bajamos el 9. En un video anterior vimos
exactamente qué significa esto: cuando escribimos
este 5 estamos en el lugar de las centenas, así
que en realidad representa 500. Sin embargo,
en este video quiero que nos enfoquemos más en
el proceso; tú puedes pensar un poco más en lo
que representan los números según su posición, y
creo que al final de este video el proceso será
tan claro como el cristal. Entonces, bajamos
el 9 y ¿cuántas veces cabe el 4 en 29? Bueno,
al menos cabe 6 veces, pero sigamos, ¿cuánto es 4
x 7? 4 x 7 = 28, entonces al menos cabe 7 veces,
pero sigamos: ¿4 x 8? 4 x 8 es 32, así que no
cabe 8 veces, pongamos el 7: 4 cabe 7 veces en 29,
7 x 4 es 28, 29 - 28 y obtenemos un residuo de 1
en este paso de la división. Y ahora bajamos el 2,
y obtenemos 12. ¿Cuántas veces cabe 4 en 12? Esta
está fácil: 4 x 3 es 12, 4 cabe 3 veces en 12,
4 x 3 es 12, 12 - 12 = 0. No tenemos residuo y por
lo tanto 4 cabe en 2,292 exactamente 573 veces,
así que podemos decir que 2,292 / 4 = 573;
y de igual manera podemos decir que esto es
igual a 573. Hagamos algunos ejemplos más,
algunas divisiones más. Esta vez tendremos 7
que divide a 6,475. Tal vez se llame división
larga porque escribimos sobre esta larga y bonita
línea, no lo sé, existen varias razones por las
que podría llamarse división larga. Pero veamos:
7 cabe 0 veces en 6, así que seguiremos
avanzando. Pensemos en el 64, ¿cuántas
veces cabe 7 en 64? Veamos, ¿cuánto es 7 x 7?
7 x 7, bueno, creo que todavía es muy pequeño,
déjame pensar: 7 x 9, 7 x 9 es 63, esto es muy
cercano y 7 x 10 es demasiado, 7 x 10 es 70,
se pasa, por lo tanto 7 cabe en 64 nueve veces: 9
x 7 es 63, 64 - 63, nos queda un residuo de 1 en
esta etapa y bajamos el 7. ¿Cuántas veces cabe
el 7 en 17? Bueno, 7 x 2 es 14, 7 x 3 es 21,
así que 3 es demasiado, por lo tanto, 7 cabe en
17 dos veces: 2 x 7 es 14, 17 - 14 es 3, y ahora
bajamos el 5. ¿Cuántas veces cabe 7 en 35? 35
está en la tabla de multiplicar del 7, 5 veces:
7 x 5 es 35 y ya está, nuestro residuo es 0. Hasta
ahora los ejemplos que hemos hecho no han tenido
residuo, intentemos otra división que tal vez
pueda tenerlo. Para asegurarnos que tiene residuo,
voy a inventar una división. Es mucho más fácil
inventar divisiones que tengan residuo que sin él,
así que tenemos 3 que divide, digamos, a
1,735,092. Esta parece en la división agradable
y enorme, y si podemos hacer ésta podremos con
cualquiera. Tenemos 1,735,092, esto lo queremos
dividir entre 3, y, de hecho, no estoy seguro
de que esta división tenga residuo. En un futuro
aprenderemos cuando un número es divisible entre
3, de hecho, podemos hacerlo ahora mismo, tan sólo
debemos sumar todos los dígitos: 1 + 7 es 8, 8 +
3 es 11, 11 + 5 es 16, 16 + 9 es 25, 25 + 2 es 27.
De hecho, este número es divisible entre 3, ya
que al sumar todos los dígitos obtuvimos 27,
y si sumamos 2 + 7 es 9 y 9 es divisible entre
3. Este es un truco que sólo funciona para el 3,
así que de hecho este número es divisible entre 3.
Déjame modificarlo un poco. Vamos a escribir 1 en
lugar de 2. Ahora este número no es divisible
entre 3 y quiero que hagamos una división que
tenga residuo sólo para que veas cómo se ve, así
que hagámosla: 3 cabe 0 veces en 1, podríamos
escribir un 0 por aquí y multiplicar, pero esto
me parece más confuso, así que avancemos. ¿Cuántas
veces cabe el 13 en 17? Bueno, 3 x 5 es 15 y 3 x
6 es 18, es demasiado, por lo tanto, 3 cabe en 17
cinco veces: 5 x 13 es 15 y restamos, 17 - 15 es
2, y ahora bajamos el 3. ¿Cuántas veces cabe el 3
en 23? Bueno, 3 x 7 es 21 y 3 x 8 es demasiado, es
igual a 24, así que 3 cabe en 23 siete veces: 7 x
3 es 21 y restamos, 23 - 21 es 2, y ahora bajamos
el siguiente número, bajamos el 5. Y creo que
ahora podemos entender por qué se llama división
larga. Bajamos el 5 y tenemos 25. ¿Cuántas veces
cabe 3 en 25? Bueno, 3 x 8 es muy cercano y 3 x 9
demasiado, entonces cabe ocho veces: 8 x 3 es 24,
y nos estamos quedando sin espacio, restamos y
obtenemos 1, 25 - 24 = 1, y ahora podemos bajar
el 0 justo así. ¿Cuántas veces cabe el 3 en 10?
Bueno, esto está fácil, cabe 3 veces: 3 x 3 es 9,
y esto es lo que más podemos acercarnos al 10, 3
x 3 es 9, bajemos la pantalla, 10 - 9 es 1 y ahora
bajemos el siguiente número. Me estoy quedando sin
colores. Con este. Bajemos el 9. ¿Cuántas veces
cabe el 3 en 19? Bueno, 6 es lo que más podemos
acercarnos, esto nos da 18, 3 cabe en 19 seis
veces: 6 x 3 es 18, bajamos la pantalla, 6 x 3 es
18, 19 - 18 es 1, y ya casi acabamos. Regresemos
al color rosa. Y bajamos este 1. ¿Cuántas
veces cabe el 3 en 11? Bueno, cabe tres veces,
porque 3 x 4 es demasiado, 3 x 4 es 12 y se pasa,
así que cabe tres veces, 3 cabe en 11 tres veces:
3 x 3 es 9, y restamos y obtendremos 2. Y ya no
tenemos nada que bajar. Si observamos por acá
arriba, no tenemos nada más que bajar, así que
hemos acabado. Por lo tanto, nos quedamos con
un residuo de 2 después de resolver toda esta
división; por lo tanto, la respuesta es que 3
cabe en 1,735,09 578,363 veces con un residuo
de 2, y este residuo de 2 es el número sobrante
que tenemos acá abajo. Así que espero que ahora
puedas resolver prácticamente cualquier problema
de división y también puedas ver a través de
este ejercicio por qué la llaman división larga.